[Music]
well
covet times have been tough for a lot of
people i forgot that it existed
you did well how how pleasant when i'm
in my house
and then when i leave i i'm reminded by
the masks that i have to wear
good job i open the door to the
restaurant i go
oops and i go back to the car and i put
it on and then i walk three steps and
then they see me and i take it off
when you sit down at the table yep i'd
be outside
oh yeah it's true well you know a lot of
people have been losing their jobs
because of this pandemic
and this one woman named alexandra
she's 27 moved to the uk three years ago
from romania to pursue a career as a
flight attendant
and she was based in london that was a
real worst career to choose
from for right now yeah they shut down
all the airlines yeah
but yeah exactly you're right why
couldn't she see the future
she lost her job because that's the
career she had
and after losing her job she
started dating this one man
who ended up getting her
to hold on to drugs for him
oh no and so she was getting paid to
hold on to drugs and then eventually he
convinced her to start
dealing these things oh my god oh my
trap like
that conversation like i know right so
she
ended up getting caught and she's
now facing time i feel like it's a real
simple conversa conversation
you know it's like hey baby you know you
lost your job and like
you know you've been i know you've been
transporting these drugs for me but how
would you like to make
you know a little money for yourself no
definitely not what if it's like
okay i'm already selling drugs but
imagine if both of us were selling drugs
yeah
that's double the income i'm in like
babe babe look how well
i'm doing with this i know what to do i
i know who the customers are
all you got to do is be in a certain
place get the money give this man a
little
little bag or box oh that's pretty good
all right i'll think about it
oh what if they're like does sound easy
hey honey here's the dress hold on to it
okay um so i know a lady that has drugs
here sits give it to these five people
before i call the cops yeah hurry up
you're a bad your brutal got caught with
the drugs already yeah dude you said i
don't know
i give you a list of five people with
addresses to deliver the drugs to you
you even go to them you were just
hesitating in the middle and she didn't
i wasn't confused because i thought you
were calling the cops on her
i am almost immediately and then you
said dude before i called the cops and
then i got lost
i got confused but she should have been
out there she should have been out the
door
you should've been out the door geo oh
but yeah so they found uh what was it
19.4 grams of cocaine
wow is that a lot i don't think so it
sounds like a lot
no it's not that's oh so it was 81 small
bags of
it's not that much oh the little little
ziplocs
yeah and so they said that they had an
estimated street value between two
thousand two hundred and thirty dollars
and three thousand
three hundred and fifty that's it so
they're gonna deport her
and they also recovered an equivalent of
more than
six hundred dollars in cash oh so she's
super small time like what's the big
deal here is it you got something
it's drugs joseph that's drugs drugs are
bad
she got sentenced to 28 months in the
slammer
damn she needs to get like a career
counselor because she chose that's
two bad jobs that's true wait first she
didn't have the foresight to see that
the airlines were gonna shut down and
then she didn't see
that being a drug dealer is also a bad
job she actually worked for multiple
airlines
innocent looking she worked for the what
and this is what they found wow
and this is a mug shot she looks way
different in the mock show than the
other pictures
she's sadder yeah she's sadder and like
she's like airlife
right here she's like she you know the
girls do that picture now yeah yeah
i want to do that one day this is my
picture of that post this one
holding that yeah oh that's a popular
pose
no you got you gotta do the point though
then you hold it with the one yeah i
have seen that
where did that come from i don't know
it's just a pose
i think it's like it's like this it's a
it's a popular pose
this is like high fashion right yeah i
never see people do that
outside of magazines well on instagram
you probably see this one more
and then the toes you got to be on your
actually i see the one where like
people spread their legs a lot that
one's really popular
yeah that is kind of popular now i think
vaginas are like on the rise of like
just more popular
you know it's like i like this one were
they never not popular no it's like
you've seen this one
everyone loves yeah like everyone loves
vaginas
but like before it's like you know your
cleavage pictures and booty pictures but
i feel like
camel toes camel toes are like are like
are popping now
and i've always been a fan of that so
i'm excited that it's it's mainstream
same here it's like a you get a slider
and then you put it to the side
it makes sense i know what they feel
like that's why
i
no no the pastries oh
wait what about macaroons they look like
they look like vaginas oh you do on the
side can you flip it
or like the pac-man bread that you could
get at the chinese
seafood store i mean the the chinese
restaurant the pac-man bread
the steamed buns yeah there you go oh
the white one
yeah and you put the duck in it oh well
for the pecking duck yeah
yeah your dick is a pecking duck
quack quack quack [ __ ] dick quack
quack
wait i'm confused okay so like
being a drug nerd this is a very small
time operation
why is this a story yeah why is it a
story because she never started like
she's 600 bucks
this isn't in the us though so it's in a
different country right it's illegal
that's pretty crazy 28 months that's
like over two years in jail
for like that little bit yeah wow
wow it's that and then also the fact
that
because like it's the headline is just
so sexy flight attendant
turns to drug dealing after losing job
amid pandemic
also it's like it's like an adventure
it's like or is it like is it like look
at what this poor girl had to do
because she don't have a job yeah she
had to turn to drug dealing
i saw like four drug deals go down
literally i think yesterday really
you know i sent you the picture of
louisiana fried chicken yes so there's a
city
in la that's known for stuff like this
and uh we were just eating fried chicken
and then we're out in the
uh outdoor seating area and there's a
dude that you could tell he's kind of
like the shock collar
and he's just sitting there and then
cars would just start pulling up into
the parking lot and i'm there eating
and i'm just looking around in the
parking lot well the seating area is
outside
so you can see the cars pulled up like
this fried chicken is good and then i'm
like wait what the hell so a car would
pull up
then there would be this lady that walks
over to the car with a butt crack all
hanging out and stuff
and her [ __ ] titties like flapping
like this you guys know what i'm talking
about
it's a separate pizza go up to the car
and then she will talk to them and they
just look like normal older folks
and then she will look back and then
look around and there's
more obvious yeah there's this one other
dude he comes over
with like he's wearing like a uh like a
tank top
and like sweatpants that are all fixed
so it's like summer up top of winter at
the bottom
then he like walks over like this yeah
and then he puts it in her hand
and she goes like this and then look
over her shoulder again yeah and then
she gives it to him
and then later she walks around with her
[ __ ] titties and ass crack hanging
out again
and then you would see the shot caller
over there look and go
and you see her just go over to the
parking lot and i was just like what's
the next one
i'm like this is crazy over and over and
over
in like 30 minutes i saw like four drug
deals go down
it all goes down to louisiana fried
chicken oh you know those cities why is
it that
every time you see one of them you have
to risk your life to eat
at that restaurant louisiana because
it's like a bank you go in
and then you know they have bulletproof
glass
like everything is like high security
for a chicken shop and when i when i was
still living in paramount it was
louisiana right there by the freeway but
it was like
like right on the border of the 91
freeway there was like that little area
right by the freeway were all like
it was it was it was an area was like
you know like
fights would break out and like there
was like a really like dusty
like motels like a hotel a motel there
was like uh for sure prostitution
is going on in this hotel and it was
like the louisiana was right across the
street and it was like damn what's going
on right here
my friend's dad owns a chain of them and
she was telling me like
one day he was basically
scrubbing the blood off of the sidewalk
from a
drive-by that went down yeah and if they
and bullets went in
to the restaurant oh damn but they
weren't open thank god
because if they were open there would
have been customers people in there
what if one of the fried chickens got a
bullet in it that'll be so crazy right
you get
you're all eating you're like oh what
the [ __ ] a nine millimeter
yeah never been to one of these places
oh dude it's so good
hands down it is worth risking your life
for and i have to say that because it is
my number one
favorite fried chicken do they postmates
that
probably not be the same it's not the
same i don't think
a lot of delivery drivers want to go to
these areas well first off
you shouldn't ever post mates any fried
chicken
that's like the worst thing possible
unless you have an air fryer at home
throw it in there for a couple more
minutes does it i'll revise it
revise it it does yeah yeah yeah yeah i
never tried it and you know here's the
thing about louisiana fried chickens too
a lot of them are connected
like they have chinese food and fried
chicken yes they do yeah
it's pretty cool or donut shop and fried
chicken yeah because they're owned by
all the chemicals a little whole little
area yeah
yeah it's pretty cool but it's the best
fried chicken that you will ever taste
and then you'll be like
oh man why didn't i know about this it's
pretty great i always used to just drive
by and then like my and rick was like yo
man louisiana is kind of like
because i love churches i love churches
this is my [ __ ] but rick was like hey
man louisiana
and then david also like when we were
shooting an episode of send foos he was
like
he he ordered some louisiana and i was
like wow this might be
this might be uh up there with churches
you guys don't even know
until you try um i wanted to ask you
guys
uh which would you be down to just
change your entire career and go towards
fried chicken
yeah if like everything you're currently
doing right now just
stopped it ceased to exist and you had
to choose a different career path you
mean like wing chuks
well what we have that's part of what we
have that's why i'm like not trying to
include any of our food groups
it's just i'm trying to think about like
what this chick was going through right
like in desperate times
she used to be a flight attendant turned
drug dealer like i don't think she was
doing it out of necessity
when there's a boyfriend involved and a
girl around
usually she's doing it out of love
it seems like it was a new relationship
based on how they're recording it so i
don't know
it's just greed because it's so much
easier though yeah that's true
there was this one movie i saw where
they were moving
um a lot of cocaine um from into florida
and then they hooked up with one of the
flight attendants and she was helping
move because back then they didn't have
any like security
like people just traveled like on planes
like it was a bus
so that could be the case too where she
was getting actually good money
i would do it
i'd go i think i'd go back into drugs
probably weed because it's legal i
honestly think i'd make a really good
drug dealer
yeah really why um just because like
i i don't think so like you know like
all the years that we've been in
business and stuff
i think i'm pretty like business minded
now so i would treat drug dealing the
same way
so even before i get into drugs i would
start
scouting and scoping the cops so as the
cops are
staring at the current drug dealer like
eating donuts and watching for eight
hours i'll be on the other side of the
street
watching cops and see how and how they
watch me eating donuts too yeah and
eating donuts too and
really figure out what they do so i can
figure out a way that
find loopholes that they're missing yeah
not gonna lie i think i would kill it as
some drug dealings
you would right yeah i think so too do
you guys feel like there is a moral
i'd feel do you think there's a moral
wronger right doing it
you mean like you're putting this into
this community
and like yeah yeah you're [ __ ] people
up i'm split because so obviously i
would never do it but
um i'm split because one it's
i do feel like you're poisoning the
community but then again it's everyone's
free will
so they're looking for this poison too
because i mean they might be already
addicted for some from some other [ __ ]
that's true
so your only responsibilities make yours
better than the other
you could try to be a you can have an
attempt of being an
ethical drug dealer by not dealing to
the people who look like
they're [ __ ] you're a mess no i don't
know i would never do it
yeah no no me neither i think i'll do
another kind of drug
um i think i'll open up a candy shop oh
yeah i'm in first customer yep
but then you're not desperate then if
you could open up a candy fine
oh true then you're just starting a new
business
candy chicken
[Music]
you